inen thank you so much for joining me
today uh tell me a little bit about your
chess upbringing oh my chess upbringing
okay well I learned to play chess when I
was around 5 years old uh my dad taught
me he was quite a good amateur player he
loved chess something that stayed with
him his whole life cuz he still plays on
chess.com every day and does puzzles and
tells me about his U you know
improvements um so my dad taught me to
play chess and he really you know kind
of cleared the path for me to to be a
chess player he taught brought me to
tournaments found my
teachers um you know made sure I was
studying right all those things that
kids need help with um and so he was a
very big part of me becoming a chess
player and uh was there something
specific that you guys were working on
uh any specific book particularly that
um stood out to you as a kid yeah well
you know actually my dad was my first
teacher until I was about 9 years old so
basically I got to around just
8,800 with his help um and I have
pictures of myself as like a little girl
like sitting on the black leather couch
with my dad working on chess with the
wooden pieces you
know um one thing I remember is that he
definitely taught me end games right I
think he kind of bought into like the
what cablanca said right that you have
to start learning chess by learning the
endgame so I think for my age like I was
always
quite decent in the end games right I
had some of that like foundational
knowledge I remember when I played one
of my first world youth championships in
bris laava in '93 I was like 9 years old
and I saved some Rook endgame down two
pawns you know and Jeremy Silman you
know was the coach back then and and he
was like he was impressed you know with
my knowledge of Rook end games and it's
because my dad uh my dad made sure I
learned them that's very nice is are the
end games still your favorite part of of
the game no they're not no of course
well you know the interesting part of
Chess I don't know it's the middle game
right so everything I love I love that I
mean the transition between opening and
middle game and the planning and the
trying to outplay you know I mean
definitely the technical part is not
like my favorite you know but yeah it's
the middle game nice in recent years I
know besides coaching you've also
started doing a lot of commentary as
well um how do you combine everything
how do you have time to do everything
yeah it's definitely a little hard um
this year has been super busy just a lot
of
traveling um well I mean
obviously you cut down on certain things
right like I don't play as much as I did
like 10 years ago I don't get I I can't
just pick up and go to any tournament
that I want to go to I have to really be
more like selective in order to manage
all these things like the teaching and
playing and the commentary um but I do
have some like thoughts of like getting
back into chess more seriously actually
in large part because of the number of
events in St Louis you know because when
you know 10 years ago there was one main
event for us women right which was the
US Women's Championship and now there's
three right there's the championship
there's the American Cup and there's the
Karen cup and that's already that makes
a big difference you know in terms of
how you how uh how viable it is to play
chess so I mean yeah I think you'll see
me playing chess more um also I know
that you've spent a lot of times uh in
the past few years focusing on your
health you are mentioning to me that um
you consider health is very important
for chess and being in shape is there a
specific sport that you practice to get
to stay in shape throughout yeah I have
to say it's one of my favorite questions
Sabina because it's really something
that I've put so much time and effort
into in the last few years and it's just
it's definitely a passion of mine the
whole like project of getting well and I
have to in a way you know you look back
and I'm very happy that I had such a
tough time with Co right that I never
just had that easy recovery because
without that I never would have been
like so into Health that I am now um but
in terms of my favor of things you know
I'm like I'm a daily Walker I mean I
walk every day for like an hour and
today I actually went walking already I
got in like let's say half of my you
know walk uh in Forest Park and I did
something else extra to kind of make it
more benefit IAL which is combining with
this idea of grounding or like earthing
it's like walking on the earth uh to
pick up those those electrons and um so
I took off my shoes and I walked on the
grass and it was uh it was actually an
amazing experience to be there in nature
this year for this competition did you
do something specific to get yourself
ready you have Eight titles of US
Women's Champion what's it going to take
to to take a few more well I mean I
didn't do anything too specific and I
have to say it's always like I always
feel like I wish I had more time to
prepare to be better prepared um but I'm
going into it like feeling quite good I
think mentally um and I do have some
ideas of some things that I'll do
differently I think to conserve
energy um and if that works out I will
tell you all about it at the end sounds
great thank you very much ER I wish you
good luck and looking forward to your
game soon thank you
Sabo
[Music]